[Música]
[Aplausos]
mudaram
joão pina alguns de vocês calhar
conhecem como tomahawk no mundo virtual
o sentimento também foi apelidado o
enredo bem e hoje estou aqui pra fora um
desenho do que a voz de portugal e
também um de nós últimos projecto foi já
não dá para esquecer porque criamos este
site esse conceito é necessário porque é
um desafio porque as entidades sociais
não fizeram
e já agora porque não há resposta a esta
pergunta pode abrir uma caixa de pandora
rui barros da rádio renascença
senão inclusive que devem ser os
cidadãos resolver este tipo de problemas
esse projeto foi basicamente fazer errar
corrigir e vou pagar ao início da
primeira versão o meia hora é construir
um time e divulgar os 25 pessoas online
nos primeiros cinco minutos
no entanto passou a ser um grande
sucesso para nós é só mais um que vem já
tem 276 pessoas está essencialmente
apenas a partilha das redes sociais nas
nossas redes sociais dos 23 e shaun
tráfego algo significativo pela primeira
meia hora da primeira hora em que está
online então entraram as outras fontes
os outros sítios onde se gera tráfego
online tivemos partidas nas redes
sociais chegaram os fóruns da
especialidade chegaram a mecânica
sociais regionais e todos os réus
começaram a trazer mais e mais pessoas
para esta plataforma
o início não estávamos também contar com
11 uma explosão visitas que tivermos um
pequeno servidor a secretária este site
em dois cortes ética
e então que os primeiros momentos no
entanto nestas coisas da internet ou ver
uma certa
diria até intensidade do consumo da
informação o site rapidamente se tornou
viral e neste momento em termos de 2.300
pessoas online
entra um destaque num país do sapo
também criada aqui na universidade da
bahia que acontece neste momento
dobramos de imediatamente as visitas
ainda assim faltava que algo mais previa
ainda mais o tráfego este site
entraram o observador e os grandes meios
de comunicação social nacionais
estamos a ter mais cinco mil pessoas em
simultâneo online e como seria de
esperar o pequeno servidor dois correm é
claramente insuficiente para suportar
tantas visitas
primeiro ele tem que dobrar nos courts
do brazilian ainda assim como podem ver
estávamos atendendo 100% precisamente ao
servir este site para as pessoas doem
sangue tem ideia do quanto custa fazer
um upgrade um servidor em termos de
tempo dois minutos e tudo isso aconteceu
sem haver o mínimo de um time
ou seja enquanto havia uma pessoa
trabalhar fazer o pleno ao servidor
fazer as configurações instalações torna
necessário o cheiro do próprio site
dois minutos foi o suficiente para mudar
um pequeno servidor protegida totalmente
novo totalmente configurado sem os
utilizadores querem dar em conta que
estava acontecendo mais partilhas mais
tráfico é via é corrida louca as bombas
de gasolina que todos assistimos e essa
informação se você vital para as pessoas
o trabalho não queriam fazer é vida do
iab é pois não havia gasolina para
limpar lado nenhum e passámos a ter sete
mil pessoas não sai mesmo tempo como
seria de esperar foi necessário fazer um
novo negócio vila
desta vez que estamos construindo 16
o 9930 isto é um servidor ou muito
grande já muito grande
será que foi suficiente pra com sucesso
o que acham sim pois já não é um grande
servidor 16 gigas né
dezesseis corpos processamento também
rapidamente passou para ser consumida
apesar do orçamento disponível
é preciso fazer neste caso
daí é preciso fazer com que ele vai ver
que é um evento um grande público muito
jovem precisa ganhar esta linguagem
torna mais fácil perceber que aquele
factor
também questiona o valor talvez e ouvir
muito falar de infectar totalmente vocês
tiverem em projetos mais antigos com
algum é que se chegue a determinado
momento em que ou já no alto falantes
seja de segurança o plantio normais dos
servidores do software que é usado em
certo momento da vida de software
precisa ser refeito é feito com
tecnologia moderna com tecnologia do
centro
neste caso ela fosse um estranho porque
o site neste momento devia ter duas três
horas em um barzinho e já só vai ser
completamente refeito
então foi feito e mais uma vez um grande
servidor pessoa é quase não têm carga de
processamento nenhuma medida acontece
hora vocês quando fazem vida um site o
servidor contar os jovens site processo
os lados faz a realização do html é que
vocês vêem o código 16 dos votos
dispositivo consegue ver tudo bem mas
como vimos a picadinha o processamento é
tanto as visitas eram antes não era
possível mais o servidor continuar a
fazer este orçamento é tudo que nós
fizemos foi pegar esta carga de saber
sair porque ela saiu e quem é o cliente
saiba todos vocês
o telemóvel ou computador só não vou
fazer nada no vosso computador não posso
telemóvel processamento é muito grande
então nós aproveitarmos essa capacidade
de processamento de votos positivos
andávamos a data deste posto de
abastecimento que já tinham e não tinham
combustível e deixar os nossos conteúdos
programados para os nossos computadores
fazerem esse procedimento o enem exata
organizarem ea carga do processamento
passou por ajustes positivos ou seja
praticamente não deram conta assis foi
uma grande diferença para nós e possa
vir uma vez mais acham onças
pois bem mais uma vez não foi só isso
e foi novamente um erro não é
precisamente a ser outra coisa qualquer
neste caso o que aconteceu foi que
sentimos limites do próprio sistema
operativo nos permitirá ter ofertas
abert ou outras configurações
necessárias para o site conseguiu
funcionar corretamente mas desta vez
optamos por uma estratégia diferente
desde o início do site estamos a fazer
aquilo que chamamos de escalar
verticalmente ou seja por mais recursos
não só servidor
neste programa disse que órgãos
horizontalmente começarmos a ter carga
distribuída por dois servidores
distintos neste caso com 4 corte em
michigan investir um grande computador
isso fez com que houvesse sucesso
então qual foram os donos já não dá para
ser o pico com mais 2 mil utilizadores
online simultânea por mais de 1.8
milhões de page views servidas mais de
um milhão de utilizadores únicos sair já
é mau o vosso computador ou 19 mil
entradas de postos que estavam
combustível sem combustível nos novos
formulários ou mais 30 voluntários e
validar que estas entradas do formulário
estavam corretas e nove erros e asneiras
outros problemas
vou explicar se o autor durante os 23
dias que este site esteve realmente a
funcionária online foram servidos 2
milhões divididos entre chefes de estado
que sejam javascript e css e o próprio
site o documento onde está o material
com vocês pois consomem na página
ao todo foram servidos 246 gigas de
dados
este equivau sensivelmente é todas as
temporadas game of thrones em 4 capa e
ainda sobra espaço para mais cerca de
som e dvd de dados é muito muito muito
tráfego
lembrando que são apenas 23 dias e
ninguém consegue ver todas as temporadas
game of thrones em 23 dias não é
obviamente que não cuida desse tipo de
projeto e estamos a falar de um projecto
é assumidamente graus assim quem são as
pessoas
introduzir o site os dados do site que
alimenta o site vai ver alguns problemas
não é o primeiro que nos deparamos foi
claramente algumas tentativas da equipe
mas achamos que isso é bom porque
permite vamos construir melhor
infraestrutura melhor jovem pra evitar
automaticamente esse tipo de problemas
por isso é que nos fechar que é bom é
uma coisa eu tenho 70 tentado alguém
estiver essa casa não é a parte má os
dados falsos uma vez mais estamos na
altura estava na altura de 9 11 e alguém
achou por bem que haveria uma estação já
sem combustível interpol
mas atenção que era aplicada muralha não
era pra lá
temos também é parte do vilão claramente
tentativas de descredibilização do site
e se você está aqui com e eram
partilhadas e achavam que por esse
motivo o site inclusive não era viável
o que acontece é de certa maneira é
preciso responder a este tipo de
situações
parte do bom uma parte do mal como parte
do vilão e como é que se faz em primeiro
lugar por mais tecnologia
oi duas três linhas escola em questão
uma lista de palavras feias
obviamente tem que estar relacionadas
aqui incluem automaticamente esses tipos
de entradas na lista do servidor
também é preciso e é muito importante
responder estas situações com
transferência porque nós próprios
publicitários nossos canais sociais
aquilo que as pessoas maldosas estava
partilhar do mouse sobre nós ou seja
tentam explicar sem porque é que isto
acontece e como é que isto acontece
isso faz com que depois conseguiu
perceber facilmente e não é nosso
problema da sociedade em que estamos
aqui neste momento o estudo o que
ganhamos por aprender a capacidade de
resposta da equipa da vossa portugal foi
fantástico e estamos a ter mais 30
pessoas olhar pra
aquelas 19 mil entradas é verificar se
não havia duplicado em viagens aéreas
havia game of thrones essas coisas todas
que é extremamente complicado fazer
estes desafios graus assim não só tendo
tempos livres dos dados qualquer pessoa
pode introduzir o que quiser mas também
temos que saber como responder nós
próprios aquelas tentativas de
descredibilização e também a necessidade
de fazer plataformas ver no ar se
escaláveis desde o início não voltará a
acontecer com os problemas e que os
autos todos os servidores não é a
natureza humana é capaz de bom do mau e
do baath e vemos é que o grupo 30
pessoas é validar os resultados temos
uma equipa de vela precisa construir o
site sempre melhorar e depois temos
aquelas pessoas entre os 12 anos
é chato foi um pouquinho do que é a
equipa da foz portugal
nós somos os voluntários em situações de
emergência somos uma equipa que faz
parte da costa eo pt acaba por ser uma
iniciativa que nasceu nos estados unidos
em 2011 e conta já com mais de 2 mil
pessoas a trabalhar com treinamento e
vou nem regime de voluntariado das
situações de emergência composta por um
imenso as pessoas com diversos credos
diferentes
temos obviamente de vela para temos
também engenheiros lojistas temos uma
imensa então de de pessoas são capazes
de atingir o espectro total para que eu
possa ser uma emergência
gostamos imenso de amplificar as
mensagens sociais informar as posições
é muito importante que a mensagem neste
caso de emergência chega não só
rapidamente o maior número de pessoas
possíveis
e também vou lhe dar informação das
redes sociais é muito comum vermos a
lusa precisa e não sei que mais
às vezes lembra lado nós temos sempre o
trabalho de tentar provar que isso é uma
verdade falamos com pj falando de
concluir isso e falamos com as entidades
sociais e só coisa que amplifica é este
tipo de coisas e também pelo produtor
ficar em casa por causa dos dados
abertos
no caso da violência doméstica são
sempre assunto nós gostamos de
participar e contribuir
esse método também temos de agir isso
tudo faz com que traga um novo
significado ao ter um e dois do teclado
estamos sempre abertos a vossa
colaboração podem participar em vós com
o pt é uma cidadania digital e uma nova
forma de atuar
um dia um membro e recentemente entrou
na nossa equipe
há bastante tempo procurou se a uma
causa porque muito se tem feito pouco
para melhorar o que aconteceu à minha
volta e triangulares filha muitos de
vocês também já pensaram isso e não sabe
por que vamos fazer
nós temos a nossa resposta podem entrar
e nós por último e finalizar a vida nem
aproveitar esse espaço aqui para
anunciar que está disponível neste
momento a nova aplicação para android e
iphone e ipad do forte com o pt
isto é mais uma mesma proporção de 10
500 pessoas que não se conhecem e se
calhar algumas notas de um falando na
internet e de juntas conseguiram
construir uma aplicação zero para uma
vez mais aos piores proporções
obrigado
[Aplausos]